a character's outfit helps to find who
the character is in the context of the
film particularly when it comes to
period pieces and superhero movies
seemingly Pony incorrect details can
cause a huge uproar among fans from
metal bikinis to sparkly hot pants let's
take a look at some of the most
controversial movie costumes and the
explanations behind them Karen Gillan in
Jumanji in September 2016
audiences got their first look at a set
from Jake Kasdan Jumanji welcome to the
jungle a new adventure inspired by the
beloved 1995 Robin Williams film in the
photo Dwayne Johnson Kevin Hart and Jack
Black are each wearing jungle
appropriate outfits alongside co-star
Karen Gillan who's wearing what amounts
to child size clothing the photo
prompted a media criticism prompting
Gillan to try and defuse controversy by
telling The Hollywood Reporter the
payoff is worth it I promise
The Hollywood Reporter later revealed
that the first footage for the film does
it's plain Gillan skimpy outfit the plot
involves four high school students who
are forced to clean out the basement of
their school while in detention they
find an old video game rather than a
board game and each choose a character
to play so is the costume meant as
tongue-in-cheek criticism of how video
games portray women maybe we'll have to
wait and see George Clooney in Batman
and Robin joel schumacher's Batman and
Robin was a disaster to put it mildly
setting aside the cartoony elements the
terrible dialogue and poor plot choices
fans will never forget the costumes
specifically the bat nipples you can
milk anything with nipples Schumacher
explained this reasoning in a Batman
special the bodies for the suits the
inspiration for them are Greek statues
that have perfect bodies and so were
molding this perfect body in rubber and
they're anatomically erotic so it never
occurred to me to not put nipples on the
men's suits because I didn't know the
male nipple was a controversial body
part Ryan Reynolds in Green Lantern
oscar-winning costume designer nyla
Dixon came up with the unique idea that
Green Lantern's costume should be a
manifestation of his power that could
have led to some pretty cool visuals
versus fans immediately realized when
the first images of green lantern were
released the special effects just
weren't up to the job
Wow I know right even star Ryan Reynolds
also complained how the costume made his
job much harder to do saying it's brutal
doing a film where you're wearing a
motion capture suit for the whole time I
didn't even get to see the Green Lantern
suit until the first trailer I never
even knew what it looked like rebel
Wilson in pitch perfect 3 even before
pitch perfect 3 finished filming the
production caught flak at the rebel
Wilson posted a photo online of herself
alongside co-stars Brittany Snow and
Chrissy Fitz causing fans online to
accuse the film of size discrimination
because Wilson's outfit had sleeves
while her co-stars had bare arms that's
right this was the start of sleeve gate
costume designer Salvador Perez
ultimately took to Twitter to try and
put out a fire I let each actor decide
how their costume fit it was their
choice rebel ester and Hannah Mae wanted
sleeves in another photo posted by kelly
j cole each of the stars i've seen
wearing a variety of styles of the same
sailor top it appears that the photo
that ignited the controversy in the
first place may have been taken out of
context and that was the end of sleeve
gate margot robbie in Suicide Squad
Harley Quinn's big screen debut in David
Ayer's Suicide Squad was one of the
movie's biggest draws especially since
margot robbie was playing the famed
villain as with any of a comic book
character a lot of media attention
focused on her costume particularly how
much of it was missing when asked about
her body hugging costume Robbie told the
New York Times that Holly was quote
wearing hot pants because they're
sparkly and fun but the actress
personally felt self-conscious about the
outfit aya defended the look by saying
that he didn't think denim overalls
would be appropriate for their character
because I clearly was the only other
possible choice Ryan Reynolds and x-men
origins Wolverine you may have blogged
it from your memory but Ryan Reynolds
played Deadpool before Deadpool
unfortunately during his first outing as
the character and x-men origins
Wolverine the filmmakers decided to make
the brave bold choice of doing
everything they could to insult the
characters fans they took away his comic
book outfits including his iconic mask
and they sewed his mouth shut
leaving a character who's literally
referred to as the Merc with a mouth
physically and able to speak
vo Adi who applied the creature effects
for the film made a video of explaining
their whole side of the Deadpool tale
the artists believe the studio didn't
intend for Deadpool to be fully formed
in Wolverine just a setup for what he
could become an elite a film this is
sort of a pre-dental if you think of
this is the embryonic Deadpool then it
might make more sense Bryce Dallas
Howard in terrific world though
audiences generally love the big dino
action there was one big problem with
Jurassic world for some fans Bryce
Dallas Howard heals which somehow stay
magically glued to her feet even when
running from a t-rex through mud rain
and wet concrete but Howard defended the
choice telling Yahoo News I'm better
equipped to roam want to have shoes on
my feet so that's my perspective on it I
don't think she would carry around flats
with her I think she's somebody who
could sprint a marathon in heels for me
it was actually logical her to be in
that very illogical situation because
she doesn't belong in the jungle and yet
she finds herself there and has to adapt
Sylvester Stallone in Judge Dredd in the
comics Judge Dredd famously never
reveals his true face a decision that
symbolic of his dedication to his job
there is no other secret identity
his helmet isn't a mask it's who he is
so it was a huge problem for fans when
star sylvester stallone took his helmet
off less than 20 minutes into the film
the reason was simple the lone celebrity
was more important than the source
material and he wanted to showcase such
famous face after all what's the point
in finding a superstar to a role when
you never get to even see him as Judge
Dredd writer Alan Grant said the story
was subservient to Stallone who I think
takes himself too seriously or in other
words Carrie Fisher and Return of the
Jedi Princess Leia's metal bikini struck
an immediate chord with adolescent male
fans of the Star Wars series from the
moment a debuted in Return of the Jedi
but while the outfit was based on Frank
possesses legendary painting the
Princess of Mars plenty of critics have
since found the Slave Leia costume to be
a prime example of sexual
objectification a sexist treatment of
the series only notable female character
at the time Carrie Fisher who played
layer and has to put up with decades of
discussion around the outfit worn the
Daisy Ridley star of the force awakens
don't be a slave like I was you keep
fighting against a slave outfit Fischer
later tweeted that chained only enslaved
me and
like a use of frabjous thing to kill
that drooling swollen super tongue slug
and whirl him off into infinity as
always Patricia had the last and best
word thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know your loved thing
[Music]